bienvenidos de nuevo bien en el último
vídeo tomamos la serie de maclaurin de
coseno de x y la representación de esta
así que supongo que podríamos hacer lo
mismo para la función seno de x quizás
suene yo muy necio pero tengo una razón
detrás de por qué estoy haciendo todo
esto y se van a dar cuenta cuando
lleguemos a la gran celebración de esto
así que de todos modos vamos sólo a ver
la serie de mclaren para la función seno
de x y bueno en este momento puede ser
bastante fácil para ti puedes hacer una
pausa y después verificar con los
resultados que tengamos en este vídeo
porque es muy parecido a la serie de
coseno de x si tuviste algún error sería
seguramente por descuido no porque no se
pasa hacerlo así que vamos a calcular
las derivadas de seno de ellos así que
la primera derivada de la función seno
de x pues es coseno de x correcto qué
tal la segunda derivada la segunda
derivada es la derivada de coseno de x
muy bien es la derivada de coseno de x
que es menos seno de x ahora si
calculamos una tercera derivada de
nuestra función seno de x es derivar
menos seno de x y la derivada de ese mes
de seno de x perdón es coseno de x por
lo cual nos queda menos coseno de x
finalmente la cuarta derivada de la
función sería derivar coseno de x que es
menos seno con el menos que ya tenemos
es seno de xy con esto ya continuamos el
ciclo verdad la quinta derivada sería la
derivada de seno de x que es la primera
derivada coseno de x verdad y así
continúa el ciclo muy bien por lo que
sabemos de las derivadas sólo vamos a
evaluar en nuestro punto x igual a cero
correcto así que la función evaluada en
cero va a ser seno de cero que es cero
ahora la primera derivada evaluada en
cero es coseno de cero que simplemente
es
kosen 10 vale 1 muy bien la segunda
derivada evaluada en 0 es menos seno de
0 que es como en el primer caso esto es
ahora hay un patrón muy similar como lo
que hicimos en la serie de coseno de x
verdad la tercera derivada evaluada en 0
es menos coseno de 0 que es menos 1 y
así no seguimos la cuarta derivada
evaluada en 0 es cero
la quinta derivada evaluada en cero es
coseno de cero que es 1 y bueno así
seguimos con este patrón verdad vamos
con un 0 positivo 0 negativo etcétera
ahora vamos a evaluar la función con
esta fórmula que tenemos del lado
derecho esto realmente va a estar
oscilando verdad entre positivo y
negativo la función oscila la función
seno özil a eso es como un juego de
palabras pero bueno vamos a ir
directamente a la representación en
serie de maclaurin de la función seno de
x que por cierto no les he demostrado
que las series de mclaren son
exactamente estas funciones verdad la
que hemos visto la de jose no la de ea
la equis o esta decena la de seno de x
perdón pero
bueno realmente he pensado cómo hacer
una prueba intuitiva no luego no he
podido hacerlo pero quiero que sea como
un salto de fe para ustedes quiero que
por el momento crean realmente que esto
converge que esta función se puede
escribir como esta serie como como la
representación en serie de mclaren muy
bien entonces esto claro es cuando la
serie es infinita en ese caso si son
iguales
en particular para este caso de la
función seno de x bueno
efe evaluado en 0 es 0 por lo que sea es
0 así que el primer término sólo es 0 el
siguiente cuando n es igual a 1 tenemos
la primera derivada evaluada en 0 que es
1 multiplicamos por x a la 1 entre 1
factorial eso de ahí abajo es 1
factorial y luego vamos a sumar cuando n
vale 2 que es 0
y restamos verdad la tercera deriva de
evaluada en 0 que es 1 por x al cubo
entre 3 factorial ahora sumamos 0 y
luego sumamos 1 por equis a la 5 sobre 5
factorial y así podríamos seguir nos
hasta adelante pero creo que ya ves el
patrón cuando lo escribimos ya limpiando
un poco todo este desorden simplemente
vamos a tener que el primer término es x
x menos x al cubo sobre sobre tres
factorial
luego sumamos x a la 5 sobre 5 factorial
ahora vamos a tener que restar ya puedes
imaginar el patrón verdad vamos a restar
x a la 7 entre 7 factorial en realidad
sólo nos estamos tomando los exponentes
impares sigue sumar x a la 9 entre 9
factorial menos x a la 11 entre 11
factorial y así seguimos adelante nos
podemos seguir adelante así que estamos
oscilando en la función seno ahí ya
habíamos dicho que era como un juego de
palabras es chistoso eso así que si
tuviéramos que escribir esto en la
anotación sigma la anotación sigma que
esto a menudo es la parte más difícil
bueno el primer termo término perdón es
cuando en es igual a cero así que
necesitamos un signo positivo
digamos vamos a tomar menos 1 a la n 1
si para que cuando en ese a 0
perdón n sea uno vamos a ver no no
esperen no esto no va a funcionar esto
debe ser 2 n 1 así es creo que en
realidad debimos haber hecho esto en el
vídeo anterior creo que me equivoqué así
que discúlpenme por el error del vídeo
anterior pero esto es menos 1 ala
am
ok no no sí creo que sí estaba bien sí
sí sí sí sí estoy bien porque realmente
nada más tengo que decir en donde
empiezo de todo estaba bien incluso en
el vídeo anterior miren déjenme
corregirlo en realidad vamos a empezar
cuando
déjenme escribirlo así esto va a ser
igual a la suma esto es la suma esto es
para que vean también que estamos en
tiempo real pero vamos a empezar desde
cero hasta infinito es la serie así que
para que el primer término sea positivo
vamos a tener menos 1 a la n verdad así
que a la 0 va a ser 1 y tendremos signo
positivo y en los siguientes vamos a
tener el signo intercambiándose ahora
multiplicamos por x
vamos a tener digamos cuando n vale 0
tenemos que el exponente tiene que valer
1 y sólo estamos tomando los impares por
lo que podemos poner 12 n 1 sobre 2 n 1
factorial muy bien así es la forma de
escribirlo y esto es bastante
interesante pero lo que es aún más
interesante es la similitud que hay
entre esta serie de mclaren esta que
estamos encerrando en un cuadrado y la
que calculamos para coseno de x en el
vídeo anterior hemos averiguado según el
vídeo anterior que coseno de x era 1 - x
cuadrada sobre 2 factoriales más x a la
4 entre 4 factorial
y menos x a la 6 sobre 6 factorial y en
fin así nos seguimos tomando todas las
potencias para es verdad aquí podría ir
x a la 8 entre 8 factorial
bueno en este caso estamos tomando las
en el caso de ccoo se no son todos los
exponentes pares incluso con sus
factoriales que están dividiendo en el
caso de seno los exponentes son impares
y los factoriales por los que dividimos
también y bueno algo que considero
bastante interesante para pensar creo
que es bastante bueno es que
especialmente lo que teníamos cuando
calculamos el coseno de x sabemos de
trigonometría que es simplemente un seno
desplazado en la función seno es un
coseno desplazado y es desplazarlo por
un ángulo de pi medios correcto cuando
dibujamos la gráfica es simplemente
recorrer los 90 grados hacia la
izquierda o la derecha según sea el caso
pero hacer eso es expresar estas
funciones esencialmente diferente verdad
ya sea tomando los términos con
exponente par o los términos con
exponente impar
pero de todas formas no importan si
ustedes no entendieron lo último que
dije mientras aprecies lo impresionante
que es esto nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo